if you don't like competition you're
probably not going to like
entrepreneurship that's just the reality
like you have to like the idea of
competing both externally and internally
with yourself to be
successful all right guys bang bang I've
got Mike here with me Mike I thought a
great place to start is almost every
single investor that you talk to will
tell you hey don't go compete with
people go do something that's different
go do something that uh is kind of this
white space you have a very different
view uh the business that you've built
literally there was incumbents with a
lot of cash there was high competition
uh and you've been very successful you
know 100 plus million dollars of Revenue
why did you choose to go take on
competition rather than do what most
people do which is run away from
competition absolutely well let's start
here like
99.9% of successful businesses that have
ever been started are in an established
field with an established product where
you're just you're tweaking the value
proposition or you're tweaking the
delivery method or there's some kind of
differentiated you know uh way of
communicating with the customer but it's
not a totally new product I mean even
things that we tend to view as
Innovative like Netflix I mean are
movies new Netflix put movies and DVDs
in the mail and then they started
streaming them and so there was nothing
even particularly Innovative about the
core product it was just the delivery
mechanism that was really Innovative and
that's basically my point is that there
are the handful of companies which it's
truly like wow this is a step change
we've never seen anything like this but
they're really rare and that if you
don't like competition you're probably
not going to like entrepreneurship
that's just the reality like you have to
like the idea of competing both
externally and internally with yourself
to be successful and so instead people
you know I I teach uh at OU at the
University of Oklahoma the entrepreneur
and residence and I've every semester I
talk to different groups of students
that are working on business plans and
it's funny how often they spend so much
time trying to come up with this unique
and bespoke idea when instead they
should just look at markets that have
lots of volume and tons of customers and
say hey how can we do this differently
or better I I like Keith reo's kind of
idea that hey just go look for a place
where there's a low net promoter score
there's lots of customers with a low net
promoter score and just do it better so
when we started simple modern one of the
things that it felt like is like man
we're just trying we have to try so hard
to get anybody to notice us to get any
kind of traction but once you start to
get the scale what you realize is the
world will constantly be in a deficit
for really excellently run companies
constantly as competitive as water
bottles are the the world still needs
more competence in making water bottles
there's billions of people and so take
that and whatever industry you're
talking about the same thing is true so
instead of being worried about hey am I
going to have to compete with others if
you say how can I do something that
serves customers where I know there are
customers who want it and I can do it at
an excellent level then there is going
to be market for you and there's going
to be an opportunity to build something
significant when you think about that
operational excellence right you're
basically saying look it doesn't matter
what the product is if you can operate
in this very effective way you can go
and you can compete how do you know
whether you are an excellent operator is
it just you've done it long enough and
and you kind of see the feedback loop of
Market success and you're like okay cool
I could go into a different industry and
I've got that operational kind of muscle
or were there things that maybe you saw
before you actually had the market
feedback where you were like I think I
can be operationally excellent and so
that gave you the confidence to go and
try this yeah I think it's it's kind of
a combination and I I'll talk about it
sequentially becoming an excellent
operator I think starts with you develop
this internal mindset of I am constantly
pushing myself to be able to do more
than I could do yesterday you know for
me that actually started with I became
awesome at Excel and I became an awesome
analyst that was actually the first kind
of rock in the foundation
and and gradually I added other rocks so
it started with me I mean there a lot of
late nights like I I think I would make
this point becoming excellent at
anything like it is a numbers game it is
an hours game like I'd like to think I'm
a pretty smart guy but a lot of it is
hours that I've put in and you talked to
some of the smartest people in business
I mean Patrick cson I've heard him say
this like hey maybe maybe somebody
smarter than me could have made stripe
without a lot of hours but I couldn't
you know it just took a lot of hours and
you talk to even the brightest minds and
Entrepreneurship they'll say the same
thing you got to put in the hours first
one of the things that I run into a lot
and I get it because I'm one of these
guys is people that are really talented
in their 20s or their early 30s and
they're like it is my time and I'm you
know I'm going to go and I'm going to
conquer the world and and often they get
a little bit over their skis they want
to do it before they've put in the hours
to really be excellent and so it's like
yeah you've got a huge IQ and yeah
you've got all the potential in the
world but you've got a mind that out
through hours of cultivating those
abilities and then I think what the
market does is the market helps you to
get an idea of where you really are
right partially the market tells you hey
here's do you have product Market fit or
not but it also gives you an idea of
like hey to compete at the very highest
levels here's what it takes and and do
you really stack up against that and I
think if you can do the combination of
those two things if you can spend the
hours and really develop pushing
yourself finding what your best is and
then occasionally you're poking your
head up and you're saying hey how does
that com how does that compare with the
landscape then you'll start to get a
feel for when you're really ready to be
an excellent operator one more piece of
advice here that I think is helpful the
more people you compete with the higher
the bar right like if you want to play
professional basketball you competing
against tens of millions of people that
as maybe aspire to that and so the bar
is exceptionally High 400 spots
exceptionally High bar um if you want to
be the best seller of um you know tree
wraps that prevent that your trees from
being damaged by a weed eater then like
okay now you're you're competing against
a few hundred people maybe or like a
much smaller subset my point is if you
start with a niche opportunity and say
Hey I want to compete at the highest
level in this Niche where I have less
competition the bar is going to be lower
and so I love the idea of develop and
hone your skills in an area where
there's not as broad a competition I
mean like we're not running away from
competition but we're also not psychotic
right like we want to find a place where
we have a chance to win and then when
you demonstrate the ability to win and
be excellent at that level then you can
start saying okay I I want a bigger
Market I want more competition so for in
in my career the very first thing I did
was a venture I did with my brother it
was an auction website and did really
well did over a billion dollars in
Revenue in about 7even years but it was
fairly contextualized the the people we
were competing against and after having
that experience and some success there I
started to feel emboldened and having
the confidence of I can go into
something as big and as competitive as
hydration where there are literally
hundreds of companies and there's high
commoditization and this really is going
to come down to how well can you operate
a company but I developed that
confidence through the hours and through
the experience of being in a more
contextualized environment where there
was maybe less competition did you just
say that your first company did a
billion dollars in Revenue in the first
seven years yeah so first company we
started we founded it October 2009
November uh right around Thanksgiving
and November 2010 uh we had our first
million dollar Revenue day I was 30 I
was the oldest person associated with
the company I wasn't even full-time this
was supposed to be like a side gig is it
really was like probably the closest
thing to like the social network where
it was just like a bunch of kids we
didn't even know what we had you know
how ridiculous what was happening was
and but man learned a ton I mean it was
like an MBA on crack you know just and
and this is really the the nature of
learning is like immersing yourself in
an environment where you can just kind
of fire hose in and learn through
iteration and fail and very quickly get
another shot at things there's also why
I love e-commerce I mean the the
responsive nature of e-commerce is
amazing if you you know 50 years ago if
you said hey what would happen if we
change the price of this product by $5
it's like well okay let's go talk to the
buyer let's let's put in the paperwork
three months from now it'll go live six
months from now maybe we know with
e-commerce you can you can make that
change live in five minutes and in an
hour you can have an idea of how it's
impacting customer behavior and so it
just really tightens these feedback
loops where you can learn much more
quickly and if you're somebody who
really does have a kind of a growth
mindset it's it's an incredible context
to to grow and develop what were you all
selling on the auction website so it was
it was it's come to be called a penny
auction website but the idea was like
the price started low and it went up a
cent every time people bid and when the
timer runs out you know whoever was the
last person to bid and you paid for your
bids um it was like it was an
interesting model I one of the things
that was interesting is when we started
it I didn't spend a lot of time thinking
about hey do I don't want to do this do
I want to be doing this six years from
now because I thought oh it'll be like a
little side project and then it became
something much bigger really quickly
where uh we we had a pretty significant
business on our hands and we had to on
the fly learn all these things like okay
how do you scale up from like our
original office it was like big enough
for five people and we had an entire
game room with like a big screen TV and
we thought oh we'll just we'll work and
then we we'll be able to watch football
you know whatever like that lasted about
three weeks you know and then all of a
sudden we had like 20 people crammed in
that space and we were busting at the
seams and so we just had to learn uh out
of necessity you know to kind of keep up
with what the business was doing it it
actually reminds me of one of my
favorite quotes about product Market fit
that when when you don't have product
Market fit it's kind of like you're
trying to push your product out to the
market trying to get people to notice
you're trying to initiate the action and
then when you get product Market fit
it's like the market pulls the product
out of you that all of a sudden you're
trying to keep up with what the market
wants as opposed to trying to convince
the market that it wants what you have
yeah that makes complete sense when you
decided to do simple modern obviously
you had this emboldened uh kind of
confidence right you you figured hey
look I can go and compete and there's
really uh um kind of uh what many people
I think thought was commoditized but you
have some unique thoughts about uh using
a differentiated strategy so it's like
go where the demand is but use a
differentiated strategy how did you
think through okay if we're going to go
do water bottles this is going to be the
different strategy or like how did you
decide what that spin was going to be
that you thought would actually give you
the wedge into the market absolutely
well one of the the things that I think
is the most significant if you're going
to build a business is to think about
Moes the idea of Moes this is a war and
Buffett term so you think about a castle
castle has a moat around it the point of
the moat is to keep people that you
don't want in the castle out of the
castle and in the same way when you're
building a business you have to be
thinking about okay my business is like
a castle and that the moment that other
smart and entrepreneurial people see
what I've built if I'm successful
they're going to want to storm the
castle and if I don't have some kind of
a moat then they're going to be able to
and everything I built is just going to
get torn right back down so if you start
from a thought process of even in the
early days how am I going to be able to
defend this because there's no point in
building it if I can't defend it it
really helps you to develop some of the
the thought processes and the strategies
that you're going to need later on so
from one I was asking the question of
like just like you said like hey this is
super commoditized industry if I'm just
selling black water bottles like there's
no way how do I hang on to market share
even if I am able to gain it how do I
hang on to that so we found a few
different uh I'd say facets that we've
really latched on to I'll name I'll name
just three or four here one that any
business owner can apply this to any
business is
culture no one can compete with your
culture right you get to own that and
that is a huge differentiator when it
comes to attracting Talent the
Excellence things get done with
retaining people all these things are
dependent on your culture and so one of
the reasons why I really B beat the
culture drum is because it's one thing
that if you do it well it doesn't matter
what happens anywhere else in the world
you can be excellent so culture was one
one was licensing so licensing is coming
into you know semi-exclusive
agreements with people that own IP and
in order to be able to put their IP on
things it's a very difficult industry to
break into you have to kind of convince
them that you have the ability to bring
value to the table even though you've
never done it before and you need IP to
do it and so it's kind of a chicken or
the egg thing but if you can get in then
you can gradually build a pretty big
portfolio and at this point we're
licensed with you know all of the
biggest players the Disneys and the NFLs
of the world uh Jerry Jones actually
played a role in us getting licensed
with the NFL so there were some really
you know key breaks we got along the way
but if you can get in there then it it's
well hey literally you have the
contractual right that no one else has
to be able to sell this product in this
particular place I think distribution
can be uh a form of moat it is not it
depends on the distribution for example
like the Amazon Marketplace is
distribution but it's not heavily moded
people are constantly coming in you're
constantly having to deal with
competition uh in other places uh with
Walmarts and targets of the world there
are buyers and so there are Gatekeepers
and usually when there are Gatekeepers
of some sort whether that's uh you know
governmental or um or legal or or just
people that are in charge of kind of
stewarding something that that can be
moded in some ways and there there's a
way to kind of protect yourself against
other people coming in um so and and
then finally one of ours is more of like
how the companies approach things is
that we're going to be fast we're going
to be built to be agile because that's
one of the ways that you prevent
disruption that anytime somebody does
something that is interesting that
challenges you you have the muscles and
the agility to be able to respond
quickly enough that they can't disrupt
you uh and so and there's probably more
but those are a few that we identified
early on in a fairly you know in our
category there's not a lot of Ip there's
not a lot of patents there's not a lot
of the vacuum insulation which is kind
of the Cornerstone uh it was in patent
and and it is out of patent so
everybody's got the same the same
materials and to me that's what makes it
so fun is I am really competing just on
merit with a whole bunch of other people
um all over the world and you know this
is a point that I like to make is that
one of the great things about being an
entrepreneur today is it's easier than
ever before to start a business you have
so many more tools I mean things like
your podcast there just so many
resources where you can literally go and
listen to the best people in the world
you can spin up a Shopify site in 30
minutes and be selling but the inverse
of that is also true there's so many
more competitors that are in the game
now you know there are people in India
for example that hey 40 years ago they
were out of the game if they couldn't
get a visa to the United States they're
out of the game but today they're in the
game and so you're just competing
against so many more people so there's
so many more tools at your disposal but
there's also so many more competitors
take the time be deliberate figure out
what are the ways that you're going to
be able to carve out and protect your
space now when you think about uh your
specific business and product it's not
like your shipping software where you
can just constantly iterate and uh it's
you know it's hard you got to have the
right product you got to go find your
customers you got to do distribution you
got to do sales you know you got to kind
of do the blocking and tackling but at
the end of the day you don't have a
physical product you guys do have a
physical product and um I I've seen you
comment uh publicly about American
manufacturing specifically and some of
the challenges there as you were getting
started how much of it was like let's go
find the demand and then figure out how
to make the product versus like hey we
got to have a warehouse full of products
in order to be able to sell these things
once we go and find the demand and so
how did you think about you know kind of
market and finding customers versus
actually having the product ready to go
uh and making sure that that was uh the
type of product and the quality of the
product that you actually would want to
sell to people yeah this is a great
question I think you always start with
sell through so what from my point of
view when you launch a product and that
could be a totally new product or that
could be like hey this new ornamentation
or this new color it's an asymmetric bet
if it doesn't work then hey your your
total loss or or your total risk is
however much you have an inventory but
your total potential gain is manyfold
you know that like it could be a 100x
that a thousand X that so we're
constantly taking wax at the pinata
every time we launch something new
there's a chance that it's going to
really resonate with customers and we're
going to have you know the ability to
have a 100 bagger a thousand bagger on
our hands so you launch things
constantly and early on what that means
is you don't worry about making it I I
do think the idea of Outsourcing the
making of things early on for most
businesses makes sense because you don't
even know where your product Market fit
is and you just need to take a lot of
wax the piñata in small quantities
really quick so that's what we did at
first is a lot of buying 500 or 250 of
something throwing it out there seeing
what happens and then doubling down
tripling down on the winners as we've
started to get to scale now it's making
sense for us to really get into the game
of making things things and as we're
getting into the game of making things
another benefit is it actually can make
us faster in some situations so for
example hey there's this new color that
just went viral on Tik Tok in the world
of whatever a year ago I would have to
say Okay well hey this is this is viral
let's order it from China it'll take 30
or 45 days then we'll bring it over on a
ship you know maybe in two or three
months we have this live where we're
going to be is where a new color goes
viral and we can pop up the next day on
social media or the next week on social
media and say Hey you know we're in
stock and because we have the ability to
create things here domestically so I do
think there's some additional kind of
demand capture and some agility that you
can get from it one other benefit of
domestic
manufacturing um is kind of you you
alluded to this the inventory piece and
we can dive into it if you want to but
the inventory piece running a consumer
brand is a lot of the complexity uh it
was so counterintuitive to me but you
can bankrupt yourself through bad
inventory decisions way quicker than you
can grow sales and if you look at a lot
of consumer brands that have gone bust
it's not actually through lack of sales
it's that they're growing and they have
a lot of sales and they blow themselves
up with inventory because you spend
money a lot quicker with inventory than
you get it back through sales so anyway
uh the inventory management piece of it
I think is is significant and if you
were at all involved in selling
inventory through let's call it 2020
through 2022 the supply chain was an
absolute disaster in in a number of ways
and there were we we had some ships just
to give some perspective we had some
product that we would order in China and
it would get on a ship and usually that
ship would take 30 days to get to the
United States some of them were taking
200 days and it's not that they were
taking 200 days to get across the ocean
they get across the ocean in 25 days and
then they would just they would just go
in circles and right outside of Long
Beach because they couldn't come into
the port and our ports were so congested
so we learned a lot during that period
about how you can get a ton of your
Capital soaked up in just inventory
that's sitting on a ship or on a dock
somewhere and obviously that blows you
up if if you're a business the closer
you're making your inventory to where
you are the more that you can manage
your inventory and the more Nimble you
can be and the more you can take
advantage of Trends that's been a lot of
the motivation for us of getting into
manufacturing but I'll also say this
it's freaking hard and it's expensive
and you have to take the Long View and I
totally see why I totally see why as
America we just kind of abandoned it
because it is hard and it's so much
easier for some consultant to come in
and say hey Outsource this to China and
you're going to be able to show
immediate savings to shareholders or
whatever but we also learned during Co
if you don't make anything here that's
really problematic you know there are
certain political environments where
that would be really problematic there's
certain Geo uh you know just global
events like Co where that's really
problematic and so we made the decision
a few years ago hey we're going to do
this even though it's hard even though
we're going to have to lay out a few
million dollars and we won't see that
return immediately uh and what's been
fun is watching our team gradually level
up in their understanding of how to be
really you know like what we talked
about like how do you become an
excellent operator well how do you
become an excellent manufacturer there's
no cheating the hours you can go out and
spend millions of dollars but you can't
cheat the hours so this is It's such a
simple example but I saw it literally
today I went by our manufacturing
facility and so we're making plastic
water bottles and we screen print on
them but occasionally the screen printer
gets messed up and something gets
blurred and so usually what would happen
is hey you throw the whole bottle away
right well they learned if you catch it
and then you just apply some rubbing
alcohol the scream right before it goes
through this UV light and gets cured
screen print comes right off bottle's
reusable and so all of a sudden we cut
our defect rate by you know whatever
from 1% to
0.25% just because they learned hey
there's there's actually a really easy
way to address this but like how do you
learn that just reps man you just got to
get in the Reps and so we're about a
year into making things we'll make about
a million units domestically this year
out of the 14 million or so that we sell
uh globally but we we have some pretty
big plans for continuing to grow our our
capabilities over the years to come one
of the aspects that I I think um if
you're a textbook entrepreneur meaning
that you just read it it in textbooks or
or blog posts you don't really
understand how important uh it is but
once you start running a business you
start thinking a lot about cash
conversion cycles and uh one of the
things that you were highlighting is you
know these boats that were sitting
outside of uh the ports for you know 100
150 almost 200 days same thing with some
of the manufacturing right you've had to
make investments and you won't see that
money come back to you for quite a while
how do you think about the investment
decisions or inventory management and
kind of cash conversion specifically
when you know the ship sitting out in
the port that's more of a short-term
thing right you're like hey I need to
get this and get this sold and and get
my cash back uh the investment in the
manufacturing is much more of a longer
time Horizon and and so you're almost
you know having to make decisions on
different time Horizons but at the end
of the day do I have the cash to pay for
the things I need is really the ultimate
you know thing you're solving for and so
H how have you kind of uh maybe informed
yourself and making the short-term
versus long-term decisions and and do
you maybe look at them differently uh on
a different axis than just you know time
absolutely so when you're early on
Anthony you have got to be turning that
cash and you've got to be growing your
Capital base we were bootstrapped so put
$200,000 of my money into the company
and we've grown that into a company
that's doing almost million in annual
sales but to you know to do that today
we might at any given point in time have
$20 million in inventory and so our
Capital base had to grow you know by
whatever like 100x so you've got a part
of the reason why the turns matter is
because you're every time you turn that
Capital hopefully you're earning a
return and you're growing your Capital
base and if you're trying to get to be a
big company you got to get that Capital
base pretty big and for the bootstrapped
you know people for the people who are
not going and raising Venture Capital
which is the vast majority of businesses
you want to be turning that Capital as
quickly as possible to be growing on
your base as time goes on and you get
more profitable and your capital base
you know you you become bankable and
your Capital base is in a good shape you
really start to think about okay how are
the ways that I can invest this money
that also creates strategic advantages
and so that's when the timelines become
less important to me like the types of
things that typically create Moes and
long-term advantages they they typically
require a significant amount of money
and the timelines are longer and because
the very reason that they create the
moat is because other people aren't
willing to do them because they're lower
return and their longer timelines so I
am a big believer that if you can take
the longest view in the room it pays off
big time but that's something you have
to earn through being successful in the
early stages where you have enough cash
and you have enough margin that you're
able to do that to start saying yes to
some Investments that can pay off two
years from now four years from now seven
years from now this is especially true
if you're competing against
corporations because corporations
obviously have a lot more capital than
you the the and and they can take on
these longer term projects the only
Advantage you have against a corporation
is that they have to be really myopic
about performance right they've got to
hit quarterly numbers they've got
investors that are really judging their
you know their report card is is in
months not years not decades and so
being this is an advantage from my point
of view of being privately held company
is that I'm able to say hey we can get
into manufacturing and that does not
have to be a huge driver of growth or
profitability for two three five years
if I think that it sets us up over the
next 10 or 20 years in a superior place
then it can be a really great place to
to reinvest cash flow that makes a ton
of sense um as you've built this uh
business you obviously had the
foundation of the first business to kind
of stand on and and it sounds like you
were doing well as a business but you
also recognize there's a lot of things I
don't know and you kind of had to you
know tral by fire you had to pick up
those skills um today I've seen you talk
about this idea of uh in order to scale
as a leader and scale your business you
really got to excel in three different
roles right kind of the player the
player coach and then the coach talk a
little bit just about you know what
exactly does that mean and then how have
you actually implemented this as you've
built the business to almost 200 million
dollars in sales yeah absolutely well
I'll start by prefacing it and saying
this is actually the reason why many
people who start companies eventually
cycle out of companies or when you hear
a Serial entrepreneur what we're really
talking about is is people who find that
they like one of these roles but they
don't like the other roles so this what
I'm about to describe is the life cycle
of a leader that you have to have if you
want to grow something from starting all
the way into significant scale in our
case we're we're talking about n figures
so the first thing that everybody needs
to hear is I don't care if you've got an
NBA I don't care how smart you are I
don't care how much money you have stage
one should be player you should be on
the field you should be getting reps if
there going to be touchdowns then you
need to be throwing them or running the
ball like this is how it has to work so
in the earliest days of simple modern
I'm literally going on every sales call
I'm also like literally I'm the one
that's setting up our Amazon advertising
campaigns you know like we're the ones
staying up late at night and talking
with the factory about nuances of lid
design like there was one lid that we
made it was a straw lid and nobody had
really made a great straw lid up until
that point from our point of view and we
could not quite get it right in terms of
the flow rate and I bet I drank out of
10,000 Lids in one summer trying to get
this thing right but this is the kind of
thing that you do you're incredibly TCT
tactical and you're incredibly more of a
generalist in your in your focused so
you need to be able to wear 15 20
different hats and you're not going to
be great at many of the things you're
doing but because you're having to do so
much of the executing and you're doing
it across a bunch of different areas you
get get this very I would say diverse
education pretty quickly and when you
talk about just growing as an operator
like man that's the way to grow as an
operator and as a piece of advice to
anybody listening to this if you're
saying Hey I want to start a business
the number one way that you can prepare
yourself go and look for a small
privately held fast growing company and
just get in the door just get in the
door it doesn't even matter what they
hire you to do you can scrub toilets if
that's how you get in the door because
what happens at small fast growing
companies is there's always a frontier
there's always this expansion that's
going on and there's always more than
can be handled by the team and if you
get in there and you start being willing
to take on new things and saying Hey
Nobody's doing this can I do this then
you're going to hear yes a bunch and
you're going to get all this opportunity
to learn in a bunch of different areas
and build that skill set and you're also
going to be able to watch some
entrepreneurs that are having success do
it and in general we're a medic like we
I I love Twitter I love all the
resources out there but I don't think
they're nearly as helpful as watching we
learn through watching and imitating
people that are doing things well so
when you've got an opportunity to do
that so the first stage is like player
there usually like it's you it's you and
a co-founder it's a small team and
you're wearing a lot of hats and you're
doing a lot of things to try and find
Initial product Market fit and get this
thing going if you have
success then we're going to go to what I
call the player coach phase which is
you've got to start to hire you've got
to start to grow the team partially
because there's too much to get done it
doesn't matter how effective you are
like there's too much that to accomplish
for you to do it all yourself and you
are probably getting to the edge of like
burnout like a lot of times this is what
happens with people that have founded
companies is they get to the point where
it's like man I've got to have some help
I've been going hard for two years for
three years whatever so you hire some
people but you now enter a phase where
the new people hired they don't know how
to do anything right they've got to be
taught and who's going to teach them
you're going to be the one that teaches
them and while you're teaching them the
train still have to run things still
have to happen and so how's that going
to happen well you're going to have to
continue to do that as well so the
analogy here as a player coach is you
are simultaneously you're having to
perform on the field while as you're
doing it coach the people that are
hopefully someday going to take these
things over and so like if you think
about a a defense in football this is
like the line linebacker who he has his
responsibilities but he's also lining
people up he's yelling at the safety
that he you know he needs to be closer
to the hash you know he's calling out
the audible based on what the offense is
doing and this is what it's like when
you're a player coach the main tension
when you're a player coach is that you
constantly feel like man if I just had
some time to think if I just had a
little bit of space I would be so much
more effective and and that's really
common and the number one pit of this
phase is a tendency to not actually
coach it's to continue to be a player
and it makes sense like what got you
here was that you were a great player
and if you allow that to Cloud your
thinking you'll continue to just press
that button when what the team needs
from you is it needs multiplication and
it needs
coaching so here's a here's a way that
this will look hey you know Sally I need
you to to do this and this on on
Amazon's advertising for me and then you
look in four hours later and you're like
hey Sally I saw that that didn't get
done and she's like yeah you know I I
was I didn't really understand how this
worked and you're like you know what I
I'll just do it don't worry about it
I'll do it that don't worry about it
I'll do it is a fatal F phrase in this
period because what it shows is that
you're you're reverting back into player
instead of Leaning into coaching the
other like reason why people will do
this is that listen the new team members
you bring on no matter how smart they
are they're not going to be as at you
right off the bat you have to make this
intentional decision of like I am
willing to take a step back in
performance to take three steps forward
tomorrow right that I could do this at
an A minus level my new higher might be
at a C+ level today but I'm willing to
take that step back in order that a year
from now they can do it at an A minus
level and my focus can be somewhere else
and so I during this phase I use I use
this like simple kind of thought process
the first you do things you have people
watch and then you talk about it
afterwards then you have you do things
but you allow people to help you while
you're doing it you talk about it
afterwards then you have them do it and
you are there sitting like literally by
their side and available to help as they
have questions and then you talk about
it afterwards and then they do it where
you're available to be consulted if if
they run into roadblocks or whatever and
you talk about it and then there's a
point by the fifth stage they're on
they're ready to now do that with
somebody else and they're ready
potentially to become a player coach uh
and then the final uh phrase like phase
I guess we say of this analogy is you're
a coach which means you're no longer on
the field and it really is all about
leading people at this point and again
this works against your your tendency
because you've been a player for so long
and for so long the organization has
succeeded because of you I'll give a
really good example of this um I learned
that I was pretty good at sales and I
loved being in Mass retail sales
conversations I mean these are these are
conversations where you can land 10 20
$30 million deals very high pressure and
and I loved it and for years I ran these
and in the last year I've made the
decision to totally extract myself from
those I've coached someone else who is a
real leader in his own right and he has
people that he is coaching and I I
totally bowed out and I got a call about
two months ago right after one of their
presentations where they had just
crushed it and Kelly who had led the
presentation and she's now like two
layers down from me she's she's telling
the story and I said I am sad I wasn't
there and I am so proud that I wasn't
there and that you did it because that's
what coaching is all about it's when
because you've done a really good job of
pouring into other people and and
developing other people you don't have
to be there and they can operate with
excellence in your absence and there's a
part of you that'll be sad about it but
it's also fantastic because now your
organization can scale the the biggest
threat in to the coach
stage is that I remember when I is
ironic I went into the coach stage right
around when coid and kind of work from
home was happening
and I I would have these days where I'm
on meeting after meeting after meeting
and I get off the last meeting my wife
says how'd your day go and I would say
man I don't know you know I talked a lot
and I tried to help people but I didn't
I don't I didn't accomplish anything
like there was nothing that got crossed
off of a Todo list and this is what a
lot of leaders struggle with initially
is that we Define ourselves by what we
crossed off the to-do list and what we
did being a coach is about developing
and not doing and so you have to make
that mental transition in order to be
effective at that or again you start
thinking I you know I need to be doing
some stuff I need to be accomplishing
some stuff and then you get in other
people's business and you're
micromanaging and it's kind of a mess so
anyway that model has been really
helpful for me and I've shared it on
social media and and I hear constantly
from people how helpful it is to them
because this is really a universal thing
that organizations go through as they
scale when you are making the
transitions between these three
different kind of roles right between a
player player coach and then Coach when
do you know to make them yeah it's a
it's a great question I I me I think
that you
aspirationally you always want to be
thinking towards the next one of like
what would it take if I'm a player coach
where do my people need to get for me to
abstract a coach because that's good
leadership good leadership is when I can
go up the next level and they can when
everybody levels up right um and so I I
think that if you're being proactive you
can identify early okay I'm coaching
this person
to be outstanding with our Logistics and
our Logistics
scheduling and here's where I feel like
they'd need to be for for that to be
possible for me to really abstract and
for them to begin coaching others and
I'm going to build towards that and I'm
going to cast vision for them of getting
to that place uh but there's also like
organizationally you you will just feel
it like in our organization when I was
still in the player coach role what I
started to really hear from people is
hey sometimes our 101s are getting
pushed because you're in a spreadsheet
and or you know I need that one-on-one
time so it's a good examp like I I came
I came to the conclusion that there was
a negative correlation to how much time
I was spending on my laptop to how good
of a leader I was being and how much I
was driving the organization because if
I was on the laptop I was doing tactical
I was doing player stuff and the
organization needed me to be a coach and
that's usually the laptop's closed and
I'm talking to people so some this is
also why it's so important to build
organizations with feedback because the
people around you on your team they will
help you to be able to pick up on hey
it's time for me to grow it and and
here's what makes it so tough Anthony
what makes it so tough is that everybody
wants to be good at their job right so
you start a company and you're like I've
got to be a great player for this thing
to work and you finally kind of claw
your way there and right when you get
there okay it's time for you to be
something totally different that you
don't know how to be very good and and
just when you get to be a pretty good
player coach okay now it's time for you
to trans transition and now you you get
to be a mediocre you know coach and so
that's another reason why we can kind of
fight against it is that we just want to
feel like we're good at things but this
is the nature of leadership when you're
doing leadership well you're constantly
feeling like you're being pushed outside
of your comfort zone when you're
surrounded by people and you have a
healthy organizational culture they'll
help reflect that to you um and and if
you kind of have a bias
to uh when it comes to your own like
thought process to say hey I'm going to
tend to want to go towards Comfort I'm
going to want to tend to stay where I'm
you know with things that I know how to
do uh how do I continue to push myself
that helps as
well another aspect of the business that
I think is unique and and uh I'm
guessing has a lot of uh kind of input
to your success is um you describe
yourselves as Mission driven and values
based uh you give at least 10 % of every
year profits uh to communities around
the world uh you say that your mission
statement is we exist to give generously
and then you describe the core value of
generosity at the heart of everything
you do from how you treat the employees
Partners vendors and customers to
affordable prices warranties and
replacement policies then on top of that
you also give a million dollars worth of
bottles and a number of other what most
people would consider philanthropic
style you know kind of efforts
this is a for-profit capitalistic
business that is very focused you know
you're talking about long-term uh profit
generation of investing in American
manufacturing so that you can move
quicker where is the value being driven
from or why is the mission driven in
kind of values based you know kind of
focus of the company so important to you
as the founder yeah okay I'll give you
three or four reasons here because I
think this is really a great question
and we're a little bit of an avatar of a
hybrid almost that I think is going to
become more more common uh just as
context for everybody listening I spent
the first 10 years of my life in the
nonprofit world I raised my salary and
so it's not shocking maybe that I would
create a company that had a different
ethos simple modern is I would say a
little bit experimental but as you said
very capitalistic Aras in the you know
tens of millions of dollars like we we
are here to drive a profitable company
first reason is the company having a
mission where I feel like I'm really
impacting the world in a positive way
keeps me and other senior leaders
engaged for a very long period of time
we can do this for our career if you
look at what drives successful
organizations compounding is a huge part
of that and being able to have the same
team together we we basically our senior
leadership team has been together now
for eight years and if you go through it
and you start asking people like about
their future plans what you would hear
is I think almost all of them would say
hey I plan on spending my entire career
here and that is a massive competitive
Advantage so when you have something
when you really can draw a straight line
from the work you're doing every day to
saying hey if at 80 I'm going to be able
to look back and say I feel good about
my contribution to the world you know
not just that we made a great business
and we impacted employees but also that
I impacted a lot of other people's lives
you know through the giving and the
different things that we did that I'm
going to feel great about that so that's
that's kept me kind of motivated the
second thing is when it comes to
recruiting you need to have a
differentiated pitch you know like let's
go back to the idea that we talked about
when it comes to markets for you to be
successful in a market that's
commoditized and competitive you need to
have
differentiation most companies don't
have any differentiation in their value
proposition to a potential employee
right it's just like well here's our
401k and we make you know 3% more than
this other job and it's like we turn
people into mercenaries quality of life
is way more complex than how much income
and benefits you know like monetary
benefits that we derive from something
there's a lot of research on this it
actually like feeling like we're how
much we feel like we're learning feeling
empowered how much we like our
co-workers whether or not we believe
that we're creating something meaningful
with our time like all of these things
really add to quality of life and I'm a
big believer in that the alpha is in
creating a company and a culture where
you drive the highest quality of life if
you drive the highest quality of life
you're going to get the best people want
to work with you and if you have the
best people wanting to work for you then
you're going to have a very profitable
company it's it's actually not a very
complicated game so we were very
intentional at thinking about how do we
create holistically the best quality of
life and obviously part of that is being
able to say to people yeah like you know
what when you go toe-to-toe with Walmart
over those five cents and it's kind of
draining but you you know you get that
concession that means that's $70,000
that can go to you know clean drinking
water right now you're not going to meet
those people but that's a whole bunch of
people that now don't have to hike you
know seven miles to get clean drinking
water every day because you did your job
with excellence in a negotiation with
Walmart and and Walmart's actually a
great example because that this is how
they would train buyers they would teach
buyers that anytime you're in
negotiation we want you to picture the
millions of customers you serve and even
if you're only saving one cent you're
putting one cent back in millions and
millions of people's bank accounts by
doing your job with Excellence so we're
we're able to recruit I think
exceptional talent I I would say that
we've probably built a team that is uh
could run a multi-billion dollar company
am we running a company that's you know
at a couple hundred million in revenue
and that's obviously uh a massive
Advantage another thing that I would say
is that I think with the internet and
transparency and just social uh
changes if you go and you you sit on a
college campus you talk to
entrepreneurial students you talk to the
most talented students this matters to
them it matters more to the generation
coming up than any other generation that
really care about hey what is the impact
of the work that I'm doing so if it's a
pretty important piece of recruiting
today it's only going to grow over the
next five or 10 years we're doing we're
building a consumer brand and like you
said a commoditized space so when it's
funny to me that you know like here's
one of our bottles we've got you know
our little SM logo on it it is amazing
to me that that same bottle because it
has those little squiggles is worth four
times a bottle that Walmart brings in
from China right but that's how we work
right we like branding matters to us
because branding tells stories about
what we believe in and about what we
belong to and the way that we think the
world should be and so if you're going
to build a great brand you better be
able to tell a story about what you
stand for and the way the world should
look and and I think that that's kind of
just to close it all off I just believe
that that's
what the world needs and that's where
it's going to go is you're going to have
companies take an even higher sense of
responsibility for the world around them
that yeah it is about driving profit but
it is also about creating the type of
world that we all want to live in and
that hopefully the work we're doing with
simple modern is a small part of that
it's interesting to hear you kind of
describe it in the way that you did
because uh most companies they don't say
it as explicitly but they all do the
same thing right if you go inside of
these organizations whether large Tech
organizations whether you go to you know
large industrial companies and kind of
everything in between at some point
there has to be something other than
just pure profit that is uh kind of
holding the team together and sometimes
it's an internal thing uh sometimes it
is an external impact thing you know
each company is different the DNA is
different the types of people but also
um my guess is that by being so open and
upfront about kind of the values and the
mission and in this idea of impact uh it
attracts the right people and it also
may be repelling the wrong people right
people who don't 100% you know get
attracted to that they're not GNA apply
to work at your business absolutely and
and listen this is one of my my things
for all the talk that we've had about
diversity and diversity creates better
teams the the best teams have no
diversity in core values like that's the
whole point what what makes it a great
team is that there isn't diversity among
the core values so like we have a core
value of Excellence we don't want you on
our team if you don't care about
Excellence right it's not for you we
don't want diversity in that area we
have a core value of generosity if you
don't like generosity then you're really
not going to like the fact that you
probably earn less because we give some
of that money away you're you're not we
aren't for you and this is part of
building a strong team and a strong
culture is that you're able to really
clearly broadcast to the world hey we're
not for everybody but if you really care
about these things we might just be
exactly what you're looking for and as a
result we've been able to create a very
cohesive team around that and I I think
that's as you're saying like that's a
Cornerstone of effective effective teams
and strong culture yeah it makes uh
makes complete sense my last question
for you is uh your daily schedule you
you now have transitioned into kind of
Coach what does that look like on a
day-to-day basis what do you do kind of
before you start you know quotequote
working what are you doing during work
and then what are you doing after uh you
get done with kind of your your um you
know more core work uh of the day yeah
absolutely so I get up take my son to
school during the work week I I
basically engage in two different types
of activities I engage in one-onone kind
of coaching with the core leadership of
the company and even though that time is
oneon-one there's not leverage in terms
of there's a lot of people there's
incredibly High leverage in terms of who
and the level of thought that's going
into that and then most most of my other
time is spent in high leverage
activities whether that's uh things that
I post in social media or that speaking
to larger groups so I I really am trying
to figure out hey how do I get the most
leverage out of my time when you invest
in the right people that can multiply
themselves it is pretty profound the
number of people that you can impact in
the amount of influence that you can
have and I think I we're at about a
hundred employees and I really see that
now that I I see people that have been
in the company for a year and I'll hear
them say a phrase that they've heard
from the person that leads them who
heard from the person that leads them
who heard it from me you know a couple
years ago so I'm very passionate about
those two things that I think the social
media involvement the speaking is I'm
also you know like I'm pretty
Evangelistic about these ideas that
we're talking about about building
businesses and about the way that you
can do it that can be impactful to the
the country in the world and I I think
there it's mainly about trying to think
about about leverage I'm an external
processor too so for me it's actually
really helpful to talk through I don't
have a lot of just sit in a room and
think time because my best thinking
actually happens when I have somebody
else like you to to bounce ideas off of
and and get some kind of dynamic
response uh and then one other thing
that's uh I guess one other thing about
my workday that's true I have we built a
gym in the office and it's been awesome
so some of my one-on ones just different
things I'll take people down there and
and I will work out as we talk and so
I've been able to incorporate uh
physical fitness into my my kind of work
schedule which has been really helpful
it helps make sure it happens and then
I'm pretty protective actually of nights
um I don't work crazy hours I mean there
there are weeks I probably put in 50 60
hours but uh most weeks are more
normative because I made a fundamental
decision that I am going to I want to be
a better father and husband than I am
CEO and I think that probably the the
critiques of hustle culture that you see
on Twitter the best critiques aren't
about hey it's evil to work a certain
number of hours I don't think that at
all I mean I've had weeks where I I laid
it all out as I'm sure many of the
people listening to this have but the
critique that I think is valid is if you
sell out relationships if you sell out
the things that really do matter in life
then why you know what's the point
what's the point in building a a big
company if you don't have anybody to
enjoy it with and if you haven't
invested uh in in the people that you
you care about the most so my kids are
are nine and 12 and those years are
fleeting and I'm not going to miss those
just because I'm running a big company
and could we maybe grow a little bit
faster if I funnel all that time in the
company sure but I don't care you know
um
and and a lot of this goes back to when
you win the game what's the point what
were you trying to win and for me I'm
not trying to amass the biggest amount
of uh dollars in a bank account you know
I'm really trying to make the most
impact and just like I was talking about
leverage earlier the number one area of
Leverage I have is in my family like
hopefully my biggest impact uh is going
to be in in the lives of my kids and my
wife and my close
friends that um that makes a ton of
sense Mike where we send people to find
you on the internet if uh if they want
to follow along I know you've been
posting a bunch of uh content I've
learned a lot from it and I'm sure other
people would as well where should we
send them yeah my Twitter at Mike
beckhams and I think uh LinkedIn I think
I have the same handle um you can catch
my stuff there I'm also uh going to be
releasing a 14-part uh podcast series
about the building of simple modern and
what we learned along the way and we
really get into a lot of the you know
everything from the tactics to some of
the questions you asked about hey how
did we do it a little bit differently
because we have this unique Mission uh
and then finally I'm a part of the
operators podcast which if you're in the
e-commerce world uh I'm with three other
guys that are running nine figure Brands
and and it's really great for learning
more about the e-commerce world yeah you
guys do a fantastic job with that I've
listened to a couple of episodes and I'm
like man I can't believe they're telling
all the secrets on here so highly
suggest people go check that out as well
all right Mike I appreciate it very much
I learned a ton I know other people will
as well and we'll definitely do it again
in the future yeah thanks for having me
Anthony and thanks for what you're doing
with your platform